Oh where are you come on come on me the
way you are I would love to come on you
but I don't know why you like there's
too many too many cooks in the whole
says the guy who made us a hangjo or
whatever without the hang zone is made
for 2 to 3 people maybe too many cooks
in the hang zone yeah you guys are
getting closer I see it's really scary
well the thing we have to go down to
file fortress all right so just so you
guys know before we go in here if we go
if you go through the end portal there's
no coming back
yeah you don't want to jump into it as a
joke unless you want to lose all your
stuff yeah it might be really funny
though have you considered what about
the goose dog what about the goose yeah
prairie an ancient library I mean so
many [ __ ] wait I'll get back in there
get back in there who where what I wanna
take some bookshelves damn it's trying
to jail you all right constable to you
doctor constable okay so somewhere in
here is a portal they'd only led us to
the entrance we have to find doc yeah
watch out for a silverfish because there
are some bear everywhere are you serious
yeah
this game has silverfish now yeah
earliest mobs when did you play this
silverfish I did play it in alpha thank
you I'm a real game oh wait I see you I
see you I see you writing the books
because well one knowledge is the enemy
of the state and to see through it a
good point no it's over here it's right
that's right Jacob yeah all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
and remind me I've been played minecraft
in bed lava hurts mr. mayor
oh we can vote in it but that would make
it dangerous because if people fall in
they'll get teleported to the end isn't
that what we wanted we could just do it
I mean I think I'll just do it right now
with none of the potions no preparations
or anything no I write into the stream I
did it without potions the first time I
did it all right pretty holy you got
there sir one thing you might not need
unless you're really unless you're
climbing up and you need to break stone
to get back down yeah but you don't not
need it so much that you should have
thrown it in the lava
yeah I'll make you a an iron you just
need one red stone yes how deep is red
stone thank you for answering my
question with yeah I got you oh I
thought you meant with my song thank you
for that anytime you guys already are
you all ready for the portal and I hid
by myself with Ryan right now Thanks I
thought you left me with Ryback back to
town then we'll then we'll prepare and
another adventure well I don't really do
failure so I hope everyone's
and I know that about you yeah it's true
I tell a lot about every morning I don't
do failure I'm like Jesus Connor I
didn't telling it we have 22 okay I need
I need one iron in three would ya
regions what do we need to fight the
dragon don't we need bows oh yeah this
is very unprepared break all the powers
which is it more important I give Ryan a
nick who come to me in the back of the
room my chat also keeps saying Jesus we
need a lot of ladders also no no we
build stairs with all the stones John
yes staircase okay round the tower okay
Rako come back make it airtight where
are you so you just you just queue it in
there wait I don't have any lava where
am I putting this through
[Music]
okay okay okay we're gonna [ __ ] die
you're gonna make a bridge over [ __ ] I
think I might already looked at my voice
yeah I'm pretty sure that the ether
stuff is making this impossible for me
al is yeah I can see this guy is white
but I have played a lot of Minecraft but
I never even tried to fight the dragon
because I always just wanted to build
cool stuff but full of tones already
complete builds a stairway down Hey okay
Ryan if you didn't already know don't
look at the the don't look it's gonna
see the black dudes just don't look at
the end of it
don't look at the tall things wait so
where we going eat a potato we're going
up dragon flies around there's towers
that each have little like eggs on top
of them you have to go to the top of
tower and break those eggs because they
heal the dragon so we can't even we
can't kill the dragon
oh [ __ ] girl we break all of those
things so we just got a climb on on top
of each of these towers correct I can't
yeah anything everything no I can't not
at all what is it look like somebody
wait if someone anger at an Enderman
will let attack all of us which is one
of us just one of us well Bruce is kind
of getting the [ __ ] beat out of him yeah
please
where are you okay do we know adverse is
well where are you oh my god where where
is he I'm right behind you guys before
this is born
oh I see him he's down here near spawn
oh my God look at all these Entenmann's
Christ okay okay okay Bruce I'm right
behind you and remind you oh [ __ ] go to
the towers that have fires oh I see I
mean I'm just trying to stay alive Bruce
yo stops the stuff that's closest to me
on the far side and then that's John's
mess down there
rising are you are you coming back here
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah can we get run back here okay
I'll teleport first don't turn around
there's an enemy right behind you do you
really want
[Applause]
oh boy yeah but I don't I don't none of
us want to attack them is the issue [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't even know how that
happened I think I may have looked at an
end Amanda now I'm dead dragon kill me
I'll take that dragons cool way to die
yeah look at the ground oh I may have
picked up some I'm sorry
somebody stuff is over by me and it is
not mine somebody picked up like half my
stuff I just I just spawned into it I'm
so sorry usually I am pro theft this
time it was an absolute accident okay
what are you what are you back I don't
feel like you need any of the rest of
this cobblestone oh do you want your
shield spinning yeah okay let me know
when everyone has all their stuff and
I'm gonna teleport us out I think give
me just a moment dragon somebody got the
coordinates right I don't have anything
let me pick these up
no you piece of [ __ ] oh you tried to
walk into my vision
and ER jail we give it a shot
this is so uncomfortable trying to pick
this [ __ ] up without someone needs to
looking into a [ __ ] Enderman why do
we need two guys Ryan sacrifice myself I
did it all right we tried we failed no
no we did not win no we did kill him it
wouldn't have counted because we use
teleporting so next time we're gonna be
prepared and you guys have to go in
knowing that we go in and you die you're
not getting your stuff back